صاله الانتقادات مسلسل بالطو واثير الجدل
حوله والسبب رؤيه البعض اهانه لمركز مطوبس
بمدينه كفر الشيخ المصريه فما القصه
المسلسل الكوميدي بلطو يتناول قسطا طبيب
حديث التخرج تم تكليفه في احدى الوحدات
الصحيه بقريته ليتفاجا بعدها بتقلده منصبه
مدير الوحده دون ترتيب ويصبح مسؤولا عن كل
شيء وفي هذا الاطار تسير احداث المسلسل
بشيء من السخريه حول مواقف طريفه يمر بها
طاقم التمريض والاطباء وهو ما اثار غضب
اهالي كفر الشيخ لما راوا فيه من استهزاء
وسخريه من المنظومه الصحيه انا شايفه انهم
ما ينفعش
لان هو بيسيء بينا وبلدنا دي بلد حلوه بلد
جميله وخرج منها سعد زغلول وما ينفعش ان
هو يتعرض اصلا
اعمل اللي انت عايزه
يعني ما تسللناش بس عادي من مسلسل كوميدي
عادي يعني ما فيش اي حاجه انا بايد
المسلسل
احمد عاطف
ارتباط بين احداث المسلسل
واهظمه المسلسل تحمل تنويه الاحداث لا تمت
للوقع بالصله وانما محض خيال ولكن هذا
التوضيح لم يقف حائلا بين المسلسل وبين
المحامي صبري الرخام الذي صمم على تقديم
بلاغ للنائب العام يطالب فيه بوقف عرض
المسلسل دفاعا عن اهل قريته لصباح العربيه
ندى حجازي كفر الشيخ